نحن الان نقف في مخزن الصحابه واحد التابع
لوزاره الصحه هذا مستودع الادويه
والمستهلكات الطبيه هنا تضع او تخزن وزاره
الصحه المستهلكات الطبيه لاغاثه المرضى
لكن قوات الاحتلال تعمدت على اهدام هذا
القطاع وتدمير هذا المستودع بشكل كامل
واحراقه هذا المخزن تعتبر يعني مخزن رقم
اثنين لدينا من اكبر المخازن في وزاره
الصحه يعني اصنافها تتعدى مثلا يعني 200
250 صنف كل الاصناف هذه الاصناف يعني مهمه
جدا لخدمه الطوارئ اللي يحتاجها شعبنا
الان يعني خلال هذه الفتره تخزن كانت في
تخزن قائمه اصناف كبيره جدا لمخزن اثنين
لمخزن الطوارئ تكون يسمى مستلكات طبيه
الخاصه بالطوارئ يعني عندما نتحدث عن مخزن
طوارئ نتحدث عن السرنجات تتحدث عن ادويه
خاصه المسلكات طبيه خاصه بالجراحات مسلكات
طبيه يعني خاصه بالاسعافات الاوليه وهذا
المخزن يعتبر من اكبر المخازن مثل المخزن
الاول تقريبا 1000 متر يعني كانت يخزن فيه
كميات كبيره جدا من المستركات الطبيه التي
تكفي وزاره الصحه لمده لمده طويله جدا من
الزمن وبسبب يعني الدمار الهائل الذي حدث
لهذا المخزن واحتراقه بالكامل الان تعاني
وزاره الصحه نقص كبير جدا من هذه
المستهلكات الخاصه ب
بالطوارئ نتحدث عن يعني خدمات رئيسيه مثل
جراحه العظام الان يعني اغلب المصابين 90%
منصاب اصابتنا اصابه جراحه عظام لان
الادوات الاساسيه الخاصه بجراحه العظام
غير متوفره بسبب يعني حرق هذا المخزن بما
يخص الغسيل الكلوي الان الادوا المستهلكات
الطبيه الخاصه بالغسيل الكلوي غير متوفره
يعني ما ما يتوفر كميه بسيطه جدا بسبب حرق
هذا المخزن حاولت قوات الاحتلال اخراج
القطاع الصحي عن الخدمه في المره الاولى
باحراق المستودعات الصحيه وفي المره
الثانيه بالسيطره على المستشفيات وايضا
اخراجها عن الخدمه لكن ما زالت وزاره
الصحه تحاول العمل على الرغم من احراق
قوات الاحتلال وتدمير كافه المخازن
الرئيسيه التابعه لوزاره الصحه اسماعيل
الغول قناه الجزيره مدينه غزه